tata first of all congratulations that
was a back and forth affair in the first
game it seemed like you got the best out
of her but she managed to survive after
that it was a 10-second game how did you
uh relieve this match
uh oh my god it's just so many games
have happened so you're talking about
like the 20 game 25 yes yeah that was so
disappointing um because i had such a
winning position i feel like once you
let it go it's kind of hard to come back
and then the second game i'm very happy
i drew and then this uh these rapid
games were very dubious
let's put it that way
how did you get ready for the rapid
games you only had uh 20 minutes in
between how did you get ready for this
um there isn't that much time to get
ready i didn't think i had any problems
in my name though so i just repeated
that and i played something excuse me
something different in my italian which
was dubious but it worked out so
let's actually uh look at that game
because that was just a wild affair
the first game let's go to the first
game the italian
i know i blundered my exchange she
didn't take it and i saw it immediately
when i played it and that was such a
horrible moment where you first you
played this move bishop from b2 to c1
which was a tremendous move offering you
the advantage uh were you surprised by
her response with g5
yeah i was and she was spending a lot of
time here i thought instead of rookie 8
she would go queen d7 and i think that
forces things a bit more because now i
think she wants to take on hto right i
takes h3 yeah so i have to go knight g3
and then bishop g6
um i had a plan here
perhaps
is that it
oh maybe queen b
three
but queen between she might still take
on h3 right bishop is too scary take on
h3 or maybe even take on d3
um how do you want to take on d3 maybe
with the bishop uh what should uh after
queen to b3 which oh you like queen b3
absolutely yeah queen victory bishop did
three now can i take only five
i don't think i hate those trades oh the
night's still no the night doesn't go
oh you just trade everything in knight
d3 right correct what was wrong with
taking on e5
wild variations here oh okay like
everything hangs here this is so
terrible
[Music]
um but after that you guys went into a
crazy melee and yeah ended up in that
position with
the b and a pawns exchanged and you
played this move rook to b1 was that a
mutual blind spot
i mean i saw it immediately after i
played it and then like the second she
didn't take it i just want my hurricane
so my rook is hanging
yeah because like in my mind i was like
i cannot go to rook bivony and then all
of a sudden my hand moves to b1 so what
can i do
and after that she played this move
bishop to g6 later on in the game
so she sidestep this exchange and then
she played this move bishop to g6 were
you shocked when you saw this move i
don't even know the evaluation of this
one how did you evaluate the position i
did not even i had seconds on my clock
you're just ready to
moving
after i did not feel good about because
there's this bishop on a7 and because
exactly here the moment we saw that you
were winning control over the f5 square
we thought you were doing very very well
we just didn't realize it was completely
yeah because at this point at
king f6 is made exactly very at first i
knew i was like what can you have six
and i was like oh that's actually really
cute that's very picturesque
and
well the yeah
she flogged here but okay she's already
falling apart here this is game over and
in the second game it felt like she was
blitzing out for her moves uh were you
aware of the theoretical situation yeah
but i mean i i was just because there
was so little time between these two
games was such a time scramble
um
yeah i don't know i thought g5 was the
best g5 was the best movie indeed
yeah okay my position all of a sudden
becomes very good
yes exactly you have this
even in the game when you have this also
rook f2 i know but i just thought like
my position is so dominant i can just do
it whenever and i got a little a little
too carried away i think no i think we
we thought you were doing very well but
especially after king g2 rook f2 right
but again like i just thought she has
nothing i can just push my pawn
right
and then i can just take on f2 but okay
now things are starting to get a little
complicated but then i remember that i
only need a dress so i can just repeat
on the fifth fret
we caught ourselves because we were
forgetting as well
yeah and then the shoulders actually go
i'm like what do i know and i was like
oh i can just repeat exactly
remarkably just at the very end i mean
of course uh we understand everything
and nerves and clocks and everything
like that but queen c2
might have really kind of tasered you in
return because you can't take on b right
uh pardon me you can't take on a3
because of uh rook b2
rook f3 rook f5 yeah and i just wanted
to say the desirable rook g3 right you
don't get your perpetual life i think
that's why she wanted
yeah exactly but
now you're in the
finals
wow
you get to play the final
you yeah to play alice lee again yeah
what's your
what's good you're going to take a
different approach for
well i mean
faster time control and i've been
playing this i think
um i feel more positive about
it very good very good well thank you
tata for joining us here good luck
congratulations congratulations
congratulations yeah today we have some
champions the champions at least